the fact is that the left and the trans
Community constantly say that biology
has nothing to do with your gender
identity so why is it that if your
biology your physical biological fact of
being either male or female if that has
nothing to do with your gender identity
then why do you need to change your
biology to reaffirm that gender identity
there's a lack in the logic here it
doesn't make any sense so if biology has
nothing to do with gender identity and a
little girl identifies as a little boy
surely going off of their whole ideology
that's enough for that little girl to
qualify or to pass as a little boy so
why is it then that they would need to
be chemically castrated injected with a
bunch of hormones to become something